♪ ♪
>> Laura: JUST 80 AFTER LEARNING
BIDEN'S TO LOAN FORGIVENESS PLAN
WOULD COST $400 BILLION, WE ARE
FINALLY SEEING A MAJOR LEGAL
CHALLENGE TO IT.
HERE WITH ALL THE DETAILS IS
TRACE GALLAGHER AND BRAND-NEW
ANCHOR OF FOX NEWS AT NIGHT.
SO EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
CONGRATS AGAIN ON THE NEW GIG.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US FOR NOW
ABOUT THIS LAWSUIT?
>> Trace: FIRST OF ALL, THE LESS
IT IS PRETTY QUICK AND DRIVE.
THAT LEGAL FOUNDATION THEIR
THURING LAW FIRM AS IS PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S PLAN TO FORGIVE HAVE TO
THE DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT
IS BLATANTLY ILLEGAL BECAUSE
VOTING BACK HERE ONLY CONGRESS
HAS THE POWER TO PASS LAWS AND
SPENT MANY UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION.
BUT IT IS INTERESTING BECAUSE
THE PLAINTIFF IN THE LAWSUIT IS
A MAN NAMED FRANK GARRISON.
HE IS A LAWYER FOR PACIFIC LEGAL
FOUNDATION OR PEER LEFT AND IT
TURNS OUT MR. GARRISON TOOK OUT
A FEDERAL STUDENT LOANS TO PAY
FOR LAW SCHOOL.
AND AFTER PAYING DOWN THIS LOANS
FOR 10 IS LOOKUPS HE IS NOW
GETTING DEBT RELIEF UNDER PUBLIC
SERVICE LOAN FORGIVENESS.
NOW, THAT IS A PROGRAM FOR
BORROWERS WHO ARE WORKING IN
PUBLIC SERVICE FOR NONPROFITS.
BUT IN THREE STATES INCLUDING
INDIA NETWORK OF FRANK GARRISON
LIVES, THE BIDEN DEBT RELIEF
PLAN WOULD SUBJECT HIM TO ESTATE
TAXES.
WHICH WOULD MAKE HIM WORSE OFF
THEN SIMPLY REPAYING HIS FEDERAL
LOAN.
AND BECAUSE OF THOSE DAMAGES,
PLF ARGUES THAT GARRISON HAS
THAT LEGAL STANDING TO SUE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
YOU SEE THE MAP THERE.
WE SHOULD KNOW FOUR OTHER STATES
ARE CONSIDERING ALSO IMPOSING
STATE TAXES ON THOSE WHO GET BY
JIM'S DEBT RELIEF.
TODAY, THAT WHAT HAS WAS ASKED
ABOUT THE LAWSUIT.
BUT WATCH.
>> BIDEN/HARRIS RESTRICTION NO
PLAN ARE TRYING TO STOP IT
BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT WILL
PROVIDE MUCH-NEEDED, AGAIN,
REALLY FOR WORKING FAMILIES.
ANYONE WHO DOES NOT WANT TO GIVE
THAT DEBT RELIEF CAN CHOOSE TO
OPT OUT.
>> Trace: THEY SAY THERE IS NO
WAY FOR HIM TO OPT OUT OF THE
TAX.
BUT WE SHOULD KNOW THE
CONGRESSIONAL BUDGET OF 30 --
ESTIMATES THE PLANT WILL COST
$430 BILLION.
OTHER STUDIES PUT THE NUMBERS A
FEW HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
HIGHER.
LAURA?
>> Laura: OH, MY GOODNESS.
TRACE, THANK YOU AND WE ARE
GOING TO BE TUNING IN.
I CANNOT WAIT ON OCTOBER 3rd.
CONGRATS AGAIN.
>> Trace: THANK YOU.
JOREN --
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW IS
KEVIN CORKE BERG -- CALEB.
THE RESPONSE TO YOUR CRITICS
SAYING THAT YOUR SUIT HAS NO
STANDING BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT AN
AGGRIEVED PARTY.
WHAT ARE THE DAMAGES TO YOU IN
THE PACIFIC LEGAL FOUNDATION?
WELL, THE QUESTION IS NOT WHAT
IS THE DAMAGE TO MEET OR THE
PACIFIC LEGAL FOUNDATION, IT IS
TO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE GETTING
THIS STUDENT LOAN CANCELLATION
FORCED UPON THEM.
AND FOR MY CLIENT, FRANK
GARRISON, WHO HAPPENS TO BE ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES, I MEAN, THE
DAMAGES ARE PRETTY CLEAR.
HE IS GOING TO BE STUCK WITH A
TAX BILL THAT HE DID NOT ASK
FOUR.
FOR THIS CANCELLATION THAT HE
DOES NOT MONTH THAT IS GOING TO
PUT HIM IN WORSE POSITION THAN
IF NOTHING HAPPENED.
AND TO THE EXTENT, THE WHITE
HOUSE JUST SAID, YOU KNOW, WE
HEARD THE CLIP.
THEY SAID, WELL, NOBODY IS GOING
TO GET THIS IF THEY DON'T WANT
IT.
THAT IS JUST NOT TRUE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
STILL ON THEIR WEBSITE TODAY
SAYS THAT AS MANY AS 8 MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE U.S. ARE GOING TO
GET AUTOMATIC CANCELLATION AT
LEAST STARTING THIS WEEK
POTENTIALLY.
>> Laura: CALEB, LARRY TRIBE
TWEETED ABOUT THE LAWSUIT SAYING
THAT BIG WEAKNESS OF IT IS THE
STRENGTH, THE STATUTORY GROUND
IN WHICH BIDEN'S PLANT STANDS
BUT UNDER THE HEROES ACT AND
UNDER THE HEALTH AND EDUCATION
ACT.
CALEB WENT ON TO SAY THAT THAT
LAWSUIT WAS A STRETCH.
SO AGAIN, FOCUSING ON THOSE TWO
ACTS THE PRESIDENT IS SUPPOSEDLY
FINDING THE ABILITY TO
APPROPRIATE ESSENTIALLY HUNDREDS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
>> Caleb: WELL, I THINK JUST
TAKING A STEP BACK AND THINKING
ABOUT HOW ABSURD THAT IS THAT IT
IS EVEN AN ARGUMENT THAT THE
PRESIDENT CAN ALL BY HIMSELF
JUST APPROPRIATE $500 BILLION.
OR, I MEAN, WE WILL TAKE THE
CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATE.
$400 BILLION.
I MEAN, THAT IS A RIDICULOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE HEROES
ACT AND THAT IS BELIEVED TO
STATUTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS RELYING ON THE
PRESIDENT IS RELYING ON, THAT
WAS A BILL THAT WAS PASSED IN
2003 IN REACTION TO THE IRAQI
WAR.
>> Laura: WE GOT TO GO.
WE GOT THE POINT.
YOU CAN GO BACK -- YOU CAN'T GO